[Music]
hi everybody happy New Year if I haven't
said it yet to you and welcome back to
the data science hangout I'm Rachel I
lead customer marketing at posit I'm
excited to be back here with you all
this is our first hangout of
2024 The Hangout is our open space to
hear what's going on in the world of
data across different Industries chat
about data Science Leadership and
connect with others facing similar
things as you we get together here every
Thursday at the same time same place so
if this is your first time joining us it
is so nice to meet you is it anybody's
first hangout say hi in the chat because
we'd love to welcome you in and uh say
hello to anybody joining for the first
time
too we're all dedicated to keeping this
a friendly and welcom space for everyone
so we love hearing from you no matter
your years of experience titles industry
or languages that you work in it's also
totally okay if you just want to listen
in here and awesome to be a part of the
party that happens in the zoom chat too
but there's also three ways you can jump
in and ask questions today or provide
your own perspective on certain topics
too so if you've been here before you've
heard this whole Spiel before but the
three ways to uh jump in are you can
raise your hand on zoom and I'll call in
you you could put questions in the zoom
chat and feel free to just put a little
star next to it if it's something you
want me to read out loud
instead and then we also have a slido
link where you can ask questions
anonymously and our team will share that
in the chat here in just a
second um a quick note that if you are
watching the recording at some point in
the future on YouTube and want to join
us live the link to add it to your
calendar will be in the details below to
join us and there's no rule that you
have to stay the whole time or talk you
can come and go as it fits your schedule
but with all that welcome I am so
excited to be joined by my co-host for
today meran Ai and ml accelerator en
enablement at TD Bank group and mirin I
would love to have you introduce
yourself too and share a little bit
about your role and also something you
like to do outside of work and you can
also educate us on how to pronounce your
last name as well because I know we
didn't get to that in the first part
yeah no worries yeah so it's uh the
proper way is mean M but you know I've
been in Canada since I was like six and
I think I I accept many different
pronunciations so you know that's not a
um so yeah so uh super happy to be here
and uh hopefully get to chat with some
of you folks um um yeah so I've been at
TD Bang group for a while now so it's
coming close to 10 years so I started as
an intern there actually and my
background is actually actural
mathematics so um I got there and you
know I wanted to be like a very good
actu do all my exams and everything but
since then I kind of deviated quite a
bit I would say um so I had some
non-traditional roles there some
Innovation teams and then sort of like
loop back into sort of more the data
science world and um now I lead like a
small team of
sort of it's fairly um I would say
diverse there's some actors in there
there's some more ml engineers and ml
scientists um and the goal is sort of to
uh you know get these sort of use cases
uh started and across the line where in
some Industries you know there are more
challenges and uh we can I'm sure we're
going to be talking about some of those
um on my sort of like free time actually
this uh this holiday season I got really
into like home automation stuff so uh
you know I I'm I'm a lazy person but I'm
also the type of person that will spend
like you know 10 hours to automate
something that probably takes like you
know a few minutes of like manual work
so it's a bit of a you know
counterintuitive thing so so yes and I
have a friend who's very into privacy
and those two things don't go well
together so home automation and privacy
typically you have to subscribe to a
bunch of cloud services so I got into
this thing called home assistant you
have your own server so it kind of took
a lot of my time so that's you know if
you want to talk to me about like you
know home automation and server
management and things like that you know
feel free that's sort of like what I'm
into right now um but yeah okay I need
to know what one of those home
automations is
then okay so um so I live in Montreal um
so Canada so it gets pretty cold and my
house I have like a home humidifier like
a whole home humidifier but the thing is
you know when the temperature drops
below certain amount and if you set your
humidity levels too high your Windows
start getting foggy so mine is like
manual I have to go down in my basement
and like manually adjust it so that it
doesn't get foggy so this whole setup I
have like humidity sensors and with an
external temperature sensor so that it
automatically adjusts so that I don't
have to do this manually so that's
that's it sounds straight forward but
that that sort of thing actually took a
decent amount of my time to to set up
but it was it was cool it was fun
awesome I love hearing about everybody's
side projects
here well Mir while I wait for questions
to come in from everybody here I thought
to get us started could you share an
example of maybe a data project or a use
case that your team has worked on I
think that's always it always helps us
kind of better understand your
day-to-day work and
challenges yeah for sure so there's some
particularly interesting use cases that
we we've worked on and typically you
know our use cases always start from
let's say a problem statement right so
so we try to position ourselves as um
not being sort of like a you know our
only tool is let's say a model and
that's what we're going to deliver to
you you know we look at the problem we
really try to discuss with a business
what what they need and sometimes you
know the answer might be you know you
need to talk to a vendor right like this
isn't something you want to do
internally and sometimes it turns out
that okay this something that we we want
to do internally one of the use cases
that was particularly interest thing was
um you know this is uh before Co times
and then during Co times where our call
centers started getting um some
operational issues and when Co happened
things just started getting worse and
worse and you know a lot of folks tried
to come up with Solutions and and
approaches to kind of solving some of
these problems but what we really
realized very quickly is that um we
don't have the proper um you know data
set curated to actually even understand
what the problem is right like and then
try to give Solutions so that was that
was a huge amount of work and initially
it started out as like building a
curated data set but then it evolved
into actually like a full-fledged um
coaching application for our call
centers and this is something that is
ongoing today and it's used quite a bit
where we give you know not just you know
metrics and things but actually we tell
the managers like this is specifically
what you need to look at and this is
what this specific person need to be
coached on so just being able to give
those sites directly to people and you
know there's a front end to it and you
know poset has been like extremely
helpful in that but the amount of like
data and you know um sort of like models
and Things That Go behind that be and
it's all transparent to the end user but
um that's one of the really cool
projects that we got to work
on that's an awesome use case thank you
for sharing that so what what does the
front end look like for them or what
what is the front end yeah and that's
the other thing so one of the other
things that we were able to do and this
is sort of like part of the accelerator
mindset in our team I guess is that you
know we work really in MVP so you know
agile is the you know flavor of the
month or at least it's been the flavor
of the month for for a while now um but
like we really kind of like you know
take that to heart in the sense that
when it started off the UI was fairly
straightforward um it was a sort of like
a shiny application it gave some
insights something
um but I would say we did like feature
releases on on a monthly basis and even
earlier on it was even faster we started
with a pilot program where we had you
know a group of advisers and they kind
of like grew and became uh became fairly
large to the point that you know it was
all of the the insurance business was
covered under this um so it started as a
shiny application then you know we
realized that um it's great things are
good but if we want to sort of like
scale it out like even further
now that it can't be done with shiny and
you you can definitely you know do
things modules and things like that um
we had the resources available to us to
kind of take it a step further and like
create like a proper backend set of apis
and create like a front end in like uh
JavaScript uh with VJs and that's how
the application is today and it's still
evolving like it's still you know
there's monthly feature editions with a
feedback from the business but the sort
of like agile way that's sort of the I
would say the main benefit of something
like this
thank you um I know when we were talking
before I guess this kind of this
continues on this topic but on our
pre-call you talked about like the speed
of reaction to business needs um and I
was just wondering how has the emphasis
on the ways you interact with business
users and that speed of reaction
contributed to your team's success um
and you can speak in terms of that use
case specifically or or a different one
too yeah I would say that is the main
sort of ingredient of success um because
at the end of the day so there's there's
maybe two two elements but that one is
very important because at the end of the
day you know a lot of times and you know
business users but just typically as a
person when you think of you know oh
this is something that I want you might
say it but then when it gets into your
hands um you realize okay like this is
what I said but actually now I realized
what I wanted is something different and
there's two approaches to this one of
the approach is you know you sit down
you do a lot of like you know workshops
and you try to create like a proper
requirements document and that's you
know for certain uses that are very like
high risk and you need to make sure you
get it right on the first try that is
appropriate but for a lot of uses um
it's better to just you know give the
user something so that they can use it
and give you feedback and then based off
of that feedback again you have to kind
of you know take it and understand' giv
this feedb does it ex and them that kind
of addes that um being able to do that
very quickly that is a huge element of
the of the success here um
because after a while we started having
this relationship with the business
where they knew that you know what we
gave them if it wasn't perfect they
could come back to us and we would take
it a step further right and having that
sort of like trust that's what kind of
enables a lot of these projects to kind
of get off the
ground thank you Alan I see see you have
a question in the chat you want to ask
that here yeah sure um hi Mar um I'm
really curious um I've seen tension in
the past with like accelerator or
innovation teams making really cool
things and then running into problems of
like how do those get supported long
term because like these little
Innovation teams usually aren't
resourced to to handle that um do you
run into that kind of tension and how
have you figured figured out how to like
make things that are sustainable and
know when to hand them off and know that
you've got Partners who can take them um
any good Solutions in that kind of
organizational area yeah for sure so
this is this is a very important point
and I think that's been one of the
biggest challenges that we've solved
sort of
incrementally um so one of the most
important things is even before starting
a use case like this and I think you
know it requires a certain level of
maturity that I would say like early on
in our journey we maybe didn't have but
we were kind of Lucky in certain ways is
you need to be very um direct with the
business and make them understand that
like look we can build this we can build
this very quickly and it's fun to do to
build but it will require maintenance
and maintenance means there's cost
Associated to that so we need to make
sure that whatever they're asking for
has benefits right like actual tangible
benefits so that when we do go back to
them and say like look I need to you
know assign like an FTE to kind of do
long-term support for this um they're
okay with funding that right so that
part is very important and you know we
need to be very direct about that very
upfront right which is why a lot of the
use cases that we we tend to support
they're fairly high value and when
they're fairly high value you go back to
them you're like look I can build this
it'll cost you next to nothing for
support we need to kind of support this
and that will kind of have some cost
typically they're they're they're okay
with that so that's one part of it the
other part of it is um you know making
things sort of standardized and when I
say standardized I don't necessarily
mean that you know make like a cookie
cutter application that kind of applies
everywhere but have these sort of like
Frameworks that you know you customize
that you know if you take somebody that
doesn't have experience in this but he's
worked on a similar application he can
come and he can support it as well so by
doing that we're able to have like a
fair small group of a fairly small group
of people that can be the sort of
ongoing support team as well as the
development team so that's that's part
of the equation then there's another
part of the equation is that you know
you start kind of looking like an IT
team once you start building all these
layers um and we're not an IT team right
so then you need to have a proper
relationship with your it team and kind
of you know set the limits of like okay
well the infrastructure you own you own
sort of like let's say even the
deployment of the applications but like
the L L2 support like if there's
something wrong with the application and
stuff then that's what we own so making
sure that you have these operating
models that kind of make this work
that's sort of like the magic recipe
because if it's all on the let's say the
analytics team side that's not really
going to be sustainable and work long
term and if it's all on the it side you
know we've seen that that doesn't work
either so having this collaboration is
really the key nice yeah a lot of that
sounds familiar we're we're still trying
to figure out organizationally how to
solve some of those things get get
support for the things that we want to
live in it versus not and and It's
Tricky so it's very tricky it's great to
hear you've got a successful model it's
really cool
thanks how did you set up those
different levels for like who
handles which applications or what what
is considered it yeah that's a good
question and you know it's a it's a
tricky one and I feel like our story is
probably not that different from a lot
of other other people so you know
initially this kind of started off as
something that's like you know kind of
you know back of the envelope and then
we got something handed to the business
and it kind of like started growing
incrementally we had the necessary
resources to make sure that from the
business's perspective we were able to
support them so and and the fact is
because these applications kind of
always get new features and get
everything they're never really in
maintenance mode it's not like oh it's
set and we just need somebody to like
make sure it runs they're always in
development kind of right so because of
that we always had the had the resources
to kind of support this and the business
you know from their perspective they
were suppored so they were super happy
we got to a point where then the
Enterprise was like okay you guys are
doing things that are like very
operational and you're kind of doing
things that like it should be doing and
when we got to that point it was like
yes we kind of agree with you but we had
already made the business case that
there's value in doing this this way
because I would say before we even got
there the discussions was like well no
this like you guys shouldn't be coding
it should be it that does it right but
once the value was there and once the
business was like wait I like what these
guys are doing then the discussion kind
of changed and it became more like okay
well you know you have the analine that
is building these things but like how do
we put all the right controls and
everything in place to make this
something that is sustainable and is
within the risk profiles that let's say
a bank like TV kind of accepts right and
that is really you know you need to
bring in a lot of Partners it's a lot of
discussions and I would say these
discussions kind of take like years
right it's not something that gets
solved like you know in a single meeting
there's a lot of back and forth until
you kind of find this Middle Ground of
an operating model where you keep your
agility but you're able to have all the
right controls in place to make sure
that you know everybody's kind of you
know feel safe and
happy so would you recommend building
something impactful for the business
first before thinking too much about
like who handles
what so I mean it depends on your
industry and it depends on how um
conservative your industry is right so
the banking industry in Canada
especially right like Canada you have
like six Banks and that's it so it's
it's very
conservative um so the risk of doing
something and hurting the bank are
almost always higher than the risk of
not doing anything at all right so in
that kind of an industry you have to be
very careful and and the truth is like
you know we do handle a lot of very
sensitive information we do have to be
very careful with these things right
like that is priority number one
whenever we're doing any
project um so in these kind of
Industries having something that is
tangible that you can get like a small
group of users to use it and see the
benefits goes a long way now how far do
you want to take it before you know you
want to have those conversations that
kind of depends on you
know how risky that application or
whatever your building is right like if
it's something that requires like really
high-risk data it's very operational
then you might want to have those
conversations very early on but it's if
it's things that you know they're very
low impact let's say the business can
live it without if it goes down for like
two weeks then you know you have a
little bit more freedom but you you do
need to build that trust with the
business and the business does need to
see um like something tangible that they
can like kind of understand and touch
because that's when the value becomes
kind of like real
to thank you I know um some people join
right after the beginning where I give
the whole spiel about how you can ask
questions so I want to remind everybody
that you can just raise your hand here
on zoom and I'll kind of keep an eye out
if you want to jump in you can put
questions into the zoom chat and if it's
something you wanted me to read out loud
just put another put a star next to it
too maybe you're in a coffee shop or
something um and then we do have the
slid link I just reposted in the chat
where you can ask things synonymously
too um I realize if I say that in the
first minute some people may have missed
that um but mirin I I'm curious if you
can like share a little bit with us
about some of the tools that your team
uses um or maybe some insights into like
key tools and technologies that play a
significant role in in your
workflows yeah for sure so um so we are
actually mid migration So currently our
our main analytics platform is a Hadoop
Enterprise platform like self-hosted on
premise um so we have tools like uh
spark spark is sort of like the main
go-to Hive for like data etls and things
like that um that's sort of like on the
infrastructure side um more on the um
sort of on the data scientist side so we
do we do use uh posit workbench quite a
bit on Prem um our insurance business in
particular uses posit workbench um the
rest of the bank tends to use Jupiter
lab quite a bit U we have sort of like
containerized Jupiter lab
environment um and we have posit connect
which is where all these sort of like
applications on front ends kind of end
up living is uh is posit connect um now
moving on to Azure so we're making a big
migration there we're very datab bricks
Centric
uh at the moment um we're looking into
other tools like Azure ML and things
like that but today it's very data bric
so it's there's a whole stack of of
tools there but data braks being the
main um sort of you know uh analytics
engine environment so again more spark
heavy um we're looking to migrate
everything that we have on posit connect
onto a new instance of posit connect in
Azure so everything will kind of get uh
get brought there
um and then for machine learning models
and everything they'll live on data
braks for now but we're looking like I
said into into other sort of more
flexible tools as
well thank you um I I appreciate it I
see leisa's comment said I think it was
at a fairly techy conference I went to
where someone said organizations are
always mid
migration
yeah um Abigail I see you had a question
in the chat do you want to jump in here
this is like a very specific question so
I know there's like so datab breas
obviously it's the notebook environment
which you know some good things and bad
things um I know they on paper have this
like vs code connector or something like
that but I've never met anybody who's
actually using it are you using it can
you speak to that thank you yeah that's
a good question so um we're not using it
I I wish we were uh but the reasons are
more because of particularities of the
way that TD has sort of like set up um
the environment so data bricks is fairly
flexible like they have a good set of
apis that you can kind of plug into so
personally I'm not a huge fan of
notebooks um I would much prefer using
like a proper ID um but connecting to
these apis has some requirements in
terms of like pad tokens and things like
that and then that has like security
considerations where it's not opened up
for us so we still do have certain gaps
which is why I I'll do a plug for for
for pause it here why we're kind of
interested in this new engagement that
pet has with data breaks of integrating
workbench into Data bricks
because for us it kind of solves a lot
of issues because we have one single
manag environment that we get access to
and then there we're like already
authenticated into Data breaks and we
can kind of use vs code and stuff so
that's sort of like hope but uh but yeah
we haven't used that uh that external
connector as of yet just because we
don't have that like external
connectivity set up okay thank you
thank you um I know you covered this a a
little bit about your team but could you
tell us a little bit more about like the
data science team structure at TD
Bank yes so TD Bank
um so TD Bank has a lot of different
lines of businesses um so you have these
various lines of businesses that each
have their own sort of like leadership
um all of the Enterprise data and
analytics is essentially under a single
leadership um and we have different what
we call like practices under these
leaderships so um you know we have a bi
practice um we have a um sort of like a
data engineering practice and we have a
AIML practice so we reside in the AIML
practice but I would say we're very well
integrated so we have very close
connections with the line of businesses
even though organization we might be
sort of like all group let's say like
all the lines of buses the ml AI
practitioners they all grouped under one
let's say VP um but we all work very
closely with our you know respective
lines of businesses so that's roughly
the the
structure do you like get together with
like Community initiatives or like
annual conferences or things like that
too yeah for sure so we have we have
Town Hall again depending on you know we
have like three different town halls
depending on who is included so we have
our own sort of like the AIML practice
and then we have the larger Enterprise
data and analytics family and then you
have the different town halls with the
lines of businesses so we do have these
like large conferences and I mean you
know the the Enterprise data and
analytics community at TD is very large
I would say probably we're talking about
you know 4,000 or so um data
practitioners so this includes the AIML
practitioners and everything um so yeah
so it's a very large group of people so
we have like subgroups that we meet we
have a larger group that we meet so it
includes a fairly significant number of
people people are a little bit shy today
I think coming back in the new year I I
notice not as many questions in the chat
but I get to just keep asking Maran as
many questions as I want here but um
Greg I see your hands raised you want to
jump in
yeah absolutely uh um I uh work for
Charles Schwab so I feel like we're like
cousins or something I don't know what
the relationship would be but there's a
history there with TD and Schwab so yeah
um one of the uh challenges that I fa
here I've been here for six years or so
um is kind of an diversion
to uh open source uh packages products
anything that's not kind of vetted at
Enterprise um purely from like a risk
perspective I've had so many
conversations
about you know even well vetted packages
like uh DLI or pandas and you know how
can we guarantee that there's no
malicious code that's going to you know
come scrape and steal all our clients um
and as you mentioned it's it's it's a
function of being in a very highly
regulated industry uh have you run into
that and how have you like maybe kind of
put uh put those fears aside and and uh
kind of you know confirm that these are
really safe and well vetted uh Tools in
in in a variety of
Industries yeah that's a that's a good
question because I would say so 10 years
ago when I started I remember so my you
know just quick background I I did my
bachelors and I did my masters and I was
like you know I'm going to Academia I'm
not I'm not going to the industry but I
was like you know PhD big commitment let
me do an internship before I kind of
like you know throw myself into this
like um you know hell that is doing a
PhD um and I ended up really liking it
but I I was always more you know
academically minded so I started working
and I started using R because I kind of
use it for my thesis and like very
quickly people are like wait what are
you using like we use SAS here we don't
use R like this is open source like how
do we know it's like the right outputs
and everything and I was very lucky
because my my manager actually he told
me's like don't listen to them you do
you you know you're you're doing great
work you do you and we kind of like
followed down that path but as I would
say like very quickly within like the
next few years um I think people started
seeing just in general like different
Pockets like you know I was in a little
Insurance pocket but I'm sure the same
thing was happening in different Pockets
um very quickly people were trying to
adopt starting to adopt these things
because it was solving a lot of issues
that you know like SAS was like way
behind and like you know by the time you
board like a new tool and you have the
license agreements and everything like
you know the the project would be like
done and implemented right so that's
started to happen and I think naturally
we kind of like went through this
direction where things started getting
accepted and I think in the meantime
what was happening is that there was
some leadership changes that were
happening like the Enterprise data and
analytics team was being created and we
were very lucky and to this day we're
very blessed that you know our
leadership they're very forward thinking
like to them it's it's a non-issue and
even to to this day like for our
Enterprise data and analytics team we're
and this is probably not super common in
the industry we're really a code first
um sort of mentality where you know for
example one of the big projects that we
have right now is creating our own
in-house um machine learning endtoend
library right so this is a big project
and we're building this ourselves and
it's using like a fully open source
stack um TD also acquired an AI company
I was one of the first bank at least in
Canada was one of the first Banks to to
do so and then after that like other
Banks started doing that as well a bit
um so I would say we've been very lucky
um that we kind of organically managed
to adopt a lot of these tools and we had
the right leadership in the right places
to kind of you know allow that with that
said um it's not always without
challenge so for example you know we
still have challenges bringing let's say
third party data uh it's not sorry not
third party data but like third party
models because it's like well what do we
know about these models right like
what's in these models so those chall
still exist and we have Partners in in
our Enterprise protect team that
actually you know they proxy all the
librar so we don't have direct access to
libraries all these libraries get
scanned before they get put on our
internal repository so we do have these
layers of control that are kind of put
in place um and you know again the other
layer of control that we have is any
model and stuff that we create right we
we can create models with anything that
we want but if we want that model to go
into production it's not like we can
take any path page or anything that we
want right um everything does get vetted
by a model validation team so that model
validation team is like okay like this
library that you're using they look into
the documentation they look at all the
methodologies methodologies that are
used and they end up vetting this they
this can be a very long process for
certain models um and you know it's
grueling and it's not the funnest thing
but these are the controls that they've
essentially had to put in place so that
we can do these things in a regulated um
environment
right absolutely I appreciate that
you're really
uh painting a good picture for a career
in mro
right
yeah there was a an anonymous question I
want to make sure I didn't forget that
was over on slido but the question was
do people use SAS at
TD I think it's finally going away so I
think up until very recently and maybe
still but I think the the goal for the
Enterprise has been to migrate
everything out to Azure so I think
everything is sort of going to be moving
into sort of like this new data bricks
platform so um there might be some small
pockets it's a very big company uh so
it's hard to know exactly what's going
on in every single spot but uh very
little sass I would say if if it's if it
is it's some Legacy stuff that you know
people just don't want
attention um Alan I see you had another
question a little bit earlier here you
want to jump in yeah thanks um I'm I'm
really curious about um scaling up to
the size of team that you have now Marin
where where you've got people dedicated
to this this ml AI space and use cases
there was there a was there a point
where there was enough support to say
yeah it makes sense to dedicate people
here as opposed to you know sort of like
catches can models where you know you
get use cases coming in and you try and
solve them um but those may be slack for
some time because up to a certain point
in time you just don't have those all
the time so I'm curious what that sort
of progression was like and how you knew
when you were like okay this is enough
to focus on to like dedicate like FTE to
um as opposed to you know sort of
filling that in as it as it happens so
uh just to be sure I answer the right
question you're referring to sort of
like AIML use cases in general or
specifically to sort of like some of the
stuff that's more like front end
application and things like that
uh I guess the way I understand your
your team to be they're focused on the
AIML use cases and so they're must be
enough of that work there's enough
volume to make sense to have that
specialization versus like kind of pool
of people and yeah and and one thing
that I can maybe like like make a
Precision about my team is that our team
actually doesn't even do that much uh
specifically AIML work in terms of like
the model development and stuff like
that actually doesn't happen in our team
so we work with our partners so our team
kind of acts as like a central spoke for
projects where we kind of coordinate a
lot of things we get things into
production if there's things to build
out more engineering Focus we do it but
the actual like AIML happens in
different practices for different lines
of businesses and the model building uh
itself that there's a huge market for
ATD like we have like between marketing
and between um you know insurance and
all the different lines of businesses um
the AIML practice I would say has tons
of work and I think the practice um that
is really focused on machine learning
and model building is around 150 people
today um and I would say they they're
fairly busy my team kind of focuses more
on the endtoend delivery of some of
these like special projects where um
it's not just like a model but it
requires like a lot of data engineering
it reques a model and it requires let's
say like a front end um and in our case
um like my team is roughly 11 12 people
um we definitely have enough work for us
as well to to do this and to be honest
in this space we really only are
catering to insurance for now um once
the other lines of businesses start
adopting this model as well I think this
team will will need to grow because one
of thing that we realize is that you
know building a model is one thing but
then making sure that the right
decisions are being made based off of
these models that's where you know
that's your last mile delivery right and
like how do you want to present this
right and you know table is great and I
know a lot of industries use use Tableau
or powerbi and things like that but um
the the part that we kind of focus on is
like okay we don't want to just give you
uh data we want to also capture data
from you right um and that's where you
know posit connect where gives you that
flexibility of deploying these like you
know proper applications like gives you
that so I would say
yeah we do have enough use cases to kind
of uh grow these things um but if we go
back you know it's been a journey of
like a few years um it started a lot
smaller right like the team might have
been like four people um kind of doing
like a couple use cases and then it kind
of like started organically growing
until a point where you know we started
having to create these specialized roles
of like you know a backend developer a
front end developer these things cool
thanks it's really really useful to hear
I really appre appreciate you flushing
out flushing that out thanks no
worries thank you um Lisa your puppy is
really interested in this conversation
too I think think we need an
introduction um this is finny and he's
seven months old and yeah so far really
loves hearing about um he was at poset
comp um you know from home so yep loving
your conversation
um ruy I see you asked a question in the
chat um I can if you want to jump in and
add some context feel I can read it I
can probably read it um so I think um I
think a lot of folks on this call are
probably working for financial
institutions or have so I um do a lot of
Consulting for financial
institutions and as you know obviously
we want to be implementing ml and be you
know building all of these tools but I
often am at the mercy of whatever
security and networks kind of
shenanigans that the client might have
um so I am subjected to their you know
security risk um financial data in
particular can be incredibly um
sensitive so I wanted to hear about how
you might have
coordinated or maybe different tooling
that you might have used to get around
or um you know work with other
teams um to build some of the tools that
you are using um I'm just kind of
getting started on this project um and
I'm just having a lot of difficulty
convincing stakeholders that you know
this is necessary data is secure Etc
yeah for sure so I think it's very
important to have like a good
understanding of their framework so I
think every larger company will probably
have their own sort of you know layers
of control right so there's privacy
Partners on one side like they tell you
you know this is the data I want to use
this is what you're allowed to do with
the data and and being able to have
those conversations that's important and
then you have sort of like the framework
that are sort of like set by whoever is
their sort of like security team right
so we call them Enterprise protect and
typically it's important to understand
sort of the guard rails that they've put
in place so in our case you know the way
that it works is that okay well you have
this Zone in this Zone you're allowed to
do XY Z and this is sort of like the
guardway that are put in place and then
if there existing patterns that you know
the architecture team has kind of put in
place as long as you stay within those
you're kind of okay now the difficulty
happens if you have like a use case that
doesn't really fit those patterns um and
that that's where it becomes challenging
so you know I can I can kind of speak to
that because we had those challenges
because when we were migrating our posit
connect platform onto Azure they were
like well the Azure environment isn't
really made to have data coming into it
in this kind of fashion right so that
again was not an easy conversation
because they had to understand exctly
what is going on they had to build new
patterns but once we got to the point
that you know the patterns were built
all the conversations were had um
Enterprise protect gave their sign off
now you have this pattern that you have
that you can reuse and kind of do
whatever use case that you need to right
so I think the the key here is to be
able to like abstract your use case into
a pattern that you can kind of explain
to the partners and say like this is
what I need to do and you also have to
be kind of like you know open at the end
of the day that they say like okay well
you know to make your data secure you
need to do XY Z and kind of like hear
them out as well so that it's not it's
not easy and especially if I take the
consultant point of view I feel like
that's particularly difficult because
you know you you're kind of like time
bound and some of these things I'll be
honest with you just take a lot of time
and a lot of you know effort to kind of
like get things going with that said the
benefit that you have on the consultant
side I think is that you know if you're
paid by the company they want to see
results so I would say use your business
uh Partners to kind of like you know
push some of those conversations along
with the the security partners and say
like you know so that they understand
the value because a lot of the
conversations that we've had you know I
can see is like if I go to them with
like a use case and I say hey I need to
do this and it requires some new pattern
they're going to be like no we're not
going to do this um and essentially if I
look at it from their perspective it's
like why am i g to bother creating some
potential risk for this thing that
you're coming to me right so you do need
to have that support from the business
side that says like no this is important
this is going to enable lots of value
for us and we need your help to tell us
like how to do this but do it within
whatever like Risk appetite that you
have once you have that support it
becomes a lot easier to kind of push
things along but you do need to have
your your business partners there that
who are you know paying you to say like
hey I need you guys to support this
because whatever you're paying me for I
can you if you know they don't they
don't help me
out thank you for such a thoughtful
answer um Gerard I see you have your
hand raised want to jump in here yeah
sure um so I'm I'm at protential and a
similar scenario where we like to hear
from external Partners on how they do
things and how they solve uh issues and
um there there's two things that uh we
use very successfully one is uh
sandboxes uh they're they're kind of the
environment that is in production but uh
it's completely separate from the
corporate Network and and there's just
nothing you can do to break things uh
and and another thing that we uh were
very good at is making fake data that
looks a lot like our data uh and then
you know ask the consultant or the
external party to develop a solution
that works within that knowing anyway
and I think I think Marin uh alluded to
this as well that no matter what
we develop there will be an IT
organization that will take that whole
thing apart build it almost from scratch
when it has to go into production
anyway yeah that's a that's a really
great point so the sandbox is very key
and this is actually I think a concept
that um at least for Our IT department
was a little bit foreign I would say
like maybe going back like a few years
because to them it was like well you
have a Dev environment and then you have
like all these like you know sit Pat
whatever you want to call it um and they
have this thing called you know sdlc
like the software development life cycle
so what they would do is typically it's
like well you work with Dev data which
is nonproduction like fake data and then
you do that but what we eventually
convinced them is that well we kind of
need a Dev but we need a Dev that's with
like real data like essentially a
soundbox because working as a data
scientist with fake data becomes a
little bit difficult right when you're
actually trying to prove results and
things so so yeah so the sandbox idea of
like you know it it looks like a
production it reads like a production
but it's not production that's something
that I think is key for any data science
team to be you know to be useful right
so that having being able to have the
freedom to do that yeah I fully agree
yeah that's a great point so as long as
you can kind of create what you need in
that environment and show the value and
everything and then whether it's it that
rebuilds it or you're able to find a
different
model that that kind of can go a long
way for
sure yeah good tip for uh for from a
data perspective and it's not an R
product it's uh it's Y data uh they have
a package that is um really well in
creating fake data oh cool by looking at
your own data so
um it learns from your data and then
generates fake uh data sets so that that
allows you to have a little bit more of
that production worthy data in a
development environment to combat the
problem that you were describing yeah
that's great
actually thank you um bill I see you had
a question a bit earlier on the model
validation team you want to jump
in and Bill I can I'll ask the question
if you want to add more context feel
free um but it was interesting that you
have model validation team what kind of
of members and what skill set are on
that
team
yeah hold on I'm hearing something in
the background not
sure where oh they muted okay um yeah so
the model validation team very important
team um very popular in terms of like
any B us doing any model they interact
with them um so that team I would say
the the background of the members
they're typically PhD um very highly
skilled in you know the academic side of
modeling like they kind of understand
really like you know all like the
splitting methods all like the little
detailed methods of you know how do you
treat your data and what impact those
things can have on your model um that's
really their their skill set um I would
say to have a particularly difficult job
as well because uh
first of all like you know everybody's
doing models right so you have a lot of
models coming from different lines of
businesses and you can't really look at
a model in a vacuum you need to
understand sort of like the business
context of the models and if you have
like a centralized team that kind of
deals with a lot of different lines of
businesses um that means like very
quickly learning about those lines of
businesses and that particular use case
right so they they also need that skill
set of like you know um being able to
talk to the business understand what is
going on and then also have a very deep
understanding on the technical side of
the um of the model so so yeah they're
very very important partner and they're
they're really key on getting so that's
that's you know one layer and then we
have a different layer that is uh um
more on the bias and fairness side so
getting the model validated is more of a
technical question of like making sure
that the model is going to produce the
outputs that you expect and and
everything um but then after that it's
like well all these variabl all these
things that you in models is it even fa
to use those in the that you're them
right so that's like a different partner
that we that we work
with thank you um as we get to the last
10 minutes here I just want to remind
people if there was a question you asked
a bit earlier anything I missed feel
free to just raise your hand here on
Zoom so I can see you as well um but
Mayan a question I love to ask everybody
here um is what is one of the most
memorable pieces of career advice that
you've either received or given
throughout your professional
Journey yeah that's a good question so
one of the things that you know so my my
manager for a long time at uh at uh TD
um so you know I I worked very closely
with him and like I wouldn't say it's
necessar an advice that they give me but
it's something that I really learned
from him like working with him and being
in meetings with him is you know like if
your vision and your goals are set in
you know in the right way right so and
when I say that you know pessimistically
you know you can look at your career and
say like well you know I want this job
so I'm going to do whatever it takes to
do that but I think the better way to
kind of look at your career is like well
what do I expect to kind of like achieve
right and what are sort of like the
vision that I have for this company
right and like think big and what are
the steps that you need to do to to kind
of achieve that like if you have that
kind of a mindset and you do everything
you know within that kind of
Direction um you will achieve great
things and not only that but you'll
bound you'll band together like a group
of people right and you have a certain
motivation because all you're doing
isn't like well you know this model is
going to bring this benefit let's just
do it and get all across the line it's
like okay well you know this for example
this call Center app um it wasn't that
you know we want to do this and like
solve solve the problem was like we
realized like oh my god like people are
on hold you know it's during for like an
hour and like we need to help them out
right like and and we did something
similar for for the claims team and it
was like people that were like waiting
for responses and they weren't getting
any and we realized okay well we need to
kind of like do something about this
right so having that kind of mindset
that you know at the end of the day like
it's the clients that matter and what's
my vision and how do I think my skill
sets are going to you know help that out
um that's sort of like what brought us
our team to this point where you know
that's what we're really doing right
it's not it's not about the application
it's not about the the models or
anything it's really about like what's
what's the end result of
this I love that thank you so much so do
do you give your team an opportunity to
like meet to talk about those big
picture things or or where do people
usually yeah for sure so we do we try to
do twice a year what we call an offsite
so we kind of get together we don't talk
about necessarily sort of like the the
specifics but we talk about um sort of
the the vision of the team and you know
sort of some of the past learnings what
went well what didn't go well um what we
want to achieve like sort of in the in
the in the coming year um we also kind
of combined that with some like like
activities just you know some team
building things like uh last time we
were we kind of got everybody in
Montreal and
we actually did like an art uh like a
little uh art uh workshop together so I
I think that kind of thing is important
because a lot of these sort of like
discussions about like vision and like
about the company and things like that
kind of arise from there and TD does
this annual and I think they're going to
make it more frequent but um what they
call TD pulse which is they sort of get
a pulse of of everybody and then we get
some of that information and um sort of
you know things about well have you in
the last last year thought about getting
a job somewhere else and we we try to
talk about those things like very openly
and try to you know make things better
not just like in terms of our work but
for ourselves right like to to be able
to produce good work everybody needs to
be happy at the end of the
day that's great thank you I'm actually
headed to Montreal at the end of this
month so I might need to ask you for
some suggestions
yeah um I don't see any questions that I
missed yet I'm going to double check
slido but I did see there's a lot of
conversation not necessarily questions
but conversations about data bricks in
the chat and I can't read through all
the comments right now but I think there
was some people kind of weren't sure
really what data bricks was when we were
talking about it would you be able to
give a little bit um more insight into
like how your team uses that or what
it's for yeah so data bricks is
essentially like a managed spark
environment so essentially imagine you
know you want to have um a cluster like
a spark cluster to work with well datab
brakes kind of lets you do that you
press a button you say I want a cluster
of like this many nodes um and then it
spins that up using whatever um sort of
cloud services so if it's Azure data
breaks it's going to be on Azure but you
can do it on AWS anywhere else um and
then you have that cluster sort of set
up so from from the data scientist point
of view I would say it's not
like you know it's nice to be able to
have that flexibility so that you can
like request what you want when you want
with that said I'm pretty sure no
company out there allows their data
scientist to spin up clusters
willy-nilly because it costs a fortune
um but what it does do is that your it
Department doesn't need to purchase a
bunch of servers and things like that
and set it up so it it allows you to
kind of like you know if you have like a
use case you can say well like I have
this use case I need like a GPU cluster
for this use case while you know you
kind of get your whoever needs to
approve it to say like okay yeah we
approved to to have this kind of cluster
to develop this use case and you have it
like you know within minutes right so
that that's essentially data BRS and
their focus is really on spark runtime
um so that's I don't know I don't know
if I did a good enough job for a data
break sales but but that's sort of like
essentially what it is right yeah and we
we didn't want to put the job of sales
rep on on you but I just saw there was a
lot of com Sation there in the the chat
about it thank you that's helpful um I I
wanted to maybe end on something you had
had said to me when we were having our
our preall is you explained some like
examples your team or use cases your
team had kind of built out with the
business and people saw it and were like
why aren't we doing this already like
how is Insurance doing this and why
aren't we doing this um and I would just
love to hear a little bit about like
that process internally like how do you
celebrate some of the work that is being
done and when people want to do
something similar how do they go about
doing it and learning how to do
that yeah for sure so one of the things
that um you know we realized is when we
do things for sort of like our our
business partners and at the end of the
day they're the they're mainly the users
here they will go and sell the thing for
us like we have the executives on our
claim side that goes and says like you
know this is the next best thing since
slice bread and they go and talk to
other Executives and you know that's
that's where a lot of these things come
from so we have a lot of support on the
business side and that's kind of comes
naturally because you know they like
what we do and they like what we do
because we do pretty much exactly what
they want targeted to them right um so
that kind of gets the word out like very
quickly um from like a top down kind of
kind of way and from a bottom up kind of
way we do have these like very similar
to this event actually where we come and
we do you know short 15minute
presentations of a use case um to the
very larger um group of like Enterprise
data and analytics teams so like I said
like this this upwards of like 4,000
people um and that starts a lot of these
conversations they like well how do we
do that and for example you know
initially TD Insurance was was using
posit connect quite a bit that's where
it kind of like started off but then you
know our Wealth Partners saw this and
they're like hey
like we have a bunch of use cases that
would be great for that we talk together
and we're like oh yeah you know and now
you know we have our personal banking
site so so things kind of start growing
organically um but yeah these sort of
events are are really useful to connect
us especially when we become like a very
big community of
people absolutely um I see Gerard asked
one last question here um any advice for
fintech conferences or what kinds of
conferences are are you you interested
in um like specific conferences um
Gerard you want to ask it here I wasn't
reading the whole thing yeah so so I get
I get I don't know how many emails I get
that ask me to go eat steak in New York
City and sit next to like a CFO or a CIO
or uh new ml Guru or whatever they're
all really really pushy uh any
conferences that you feel are very much
in the fintech in the insurance banking
industry that are for practitioners and
not for I guess posers yeah that's a
good question because you know there's
the big insure Tech in Vegas I think
that that one is I think I I haven't
been to that one but I know a lot of the
partners on the business side that I
work with um that's basically the only
one that they end up going to because
that's where you know you get most of
the vendors that are interesting and
every other one kind of becomes very syy
um but that is very more that's like
very like sales focused I would say like
it's it's a higher level on the on the
more practitioner Focus I'll be honest I
haven't seen many like great um sort of
conferences I think you know the posit
conf one being actually like a pretty
good one um and they're kind of like far
and Fe between I know Anaconda does
something very similar so that might be
uh you
know something but if you know of any
please let me know because I've I've
kind of struggled because some of these
more sales focused one we do have people
that go to them but I always want to
send my team to some of these more
interesting ones that are practitioner
focused and they they're kind of like
few and far in between posic comp being
one of the rare ones but yeah there
isn't there isn't that
many I guess I would love to ask you all
then what would you like to to
see that would help me help me in
planning too not that we're planning any
steak dinners
but I don't know a lot of these
conferences seem to be focused on like
one or the other where um either you
have people that are sort of you know
selling you know these platforms and
things like that or you have um you know
smaller meetups that are like very
technical focus in like a very specific
kind of area I think having a conference
where you kind of see you know some
endtoend projects where you know there's
the development portion of it but
there's also like some talks about like
how this thing even got deployed right
understanding what that flow kind of
looks like for people I think that
that's one of the things that would be
very interesting to
see cool well thank you all so much for
joining us today thank you so much meron
for sharing your
experience kicking us off in
2024 have a great rest of the day
everybody